Hola qué tal Buenos días se espera que
esta delegación realice un proceso de
consultas internas en territorio
venezolano antes de viajar a Colombia Si
es el caso para reanudar estas
conversaciones con el gobierno de Petro
que recordemos estas conversaciones
habían iniciado en 2017 bajo la
administración de Juan Manuel Santos
pero fueron suspendidas en 2019 tras un
atentado de la guerrilla del Ln a una
escuela de Cadetes en Bogotá recordemos
que hace tres semanas el propio
presidente Petro contactó a Nicolás
Maduro para que fuera garante de este
proceso y tal y como lo decías la
vicepresidenta delsy Rodríguez
confirmaba y daba la bienvenida que se
cumplieran estos protocolos que
consistían en que la delegación que
estaba en la Habana Cuba pudiese
retornar pasando por territorio
venezolano sin miedo a ser detenidos de
hecho este domingo el canciller
colombiano confirmaba que se habían
levantado las órdenes de extradición de
las principales cabecillas
de esta organización del Ln alias Pablo
Beltrán y alias Aureliano carbonell Pues
he explicado que no se podía negociar
teniendo a estas personas con orden de
extradición y con el temor de que
pudieran ser detenidos en el proceso
hasta el momento no se conoce la agenda
que va a tener esta delegación en
territorio venezolano Pero también es
cierto que ha sido criticado por la
oposición venezolana pues es una muestra
de la protección que bajo el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro tiene la guerrilla del Ln
en Venezuela desde hace varios años
Daniela también esto se da tras un
intercambio detenidos entre Estados
Unidos y Venezuela Cuáles son entonces
las reacciones a la liberación de los
llamados narcosobrinos
esta noticia impactó al fin de semana
pues para mucho fue sorpresiva hubo un
comunicado por parte de Juan guaidó
considerado presidente interino de
Venezuela por Estados Unidos quien decía
que no tuvo nada que ver en estas
negociaciones entre el gobierno de Joe
biden y el gobierno de Nicolás maduro y
que no había sido un intercambio
equilibrado Pues habían canjeado dos
criminales refiriéndose a Franky
Francisco Flores de freitas y Efraín
Campos flores sobrinos de la pareja
presidencial que habían sido condenados
a 18 años de prisión por narcotráfico
por siete ciudadanos estadounidenses
cinco de ellos ejecutivos de psico
filial de pedevesa en Houston que habían
sido detenidos y secuestrados
injustamente por el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro organizaciones no gubernamentales
también se han referido y dice que esto
sienta un grave precedente pues ratifica
que los presos políticos en Venezuela
son usados como fichas de canje para
del gobierno de Nicolás maduro y que
esto representa un riesgo también para
los ciudadanos de todas las
nacionalidades que pueden ser detenidos
en Venezuela para posteriormente hacer
este tipo de intercambios por su parte
el gobierno venezolano ha celebrado esta
decisión pues ellos consideraban que los
sobrinos de la pareja presidencial
habían sido secuestrados en por Estados
Unidos